hello everyone and welcome to the first
game that we are going to cover from the
second leg of the meltwater champions
chess store it's not really the second
like the second event which is now
renamed to the charity cup uh it's a
game from round two pentagram versus
magnus carlsen and it's just a very very
exciting in the game
but it's rapid time format so players
really do not have time to make some
very important decisions uh hence a lot
of the decisions that have been made
are questionable only when inspected
with uh you know uh the help of our uh
great friend the engine uh but uh you
know when you're actually playing the
game it looks like everything is on fire
and that anything could go wrong and
everything does go wrong so let's dive
straight into it as it's very very
enjoyable so hari krishna with the white
pieces opens with e4 and the magnus
prepared something very special for uh
well or rather against e4 this this
tournament and that is e6 he goes for
the french defense uh we have d for d5
and now knight to c3 so just the
standard french we have knight to f6 e5
and now knight f to d7 this is the stein
it's variation and usually this is met
with f4 but here hare krishna goes for
knight c to e2 this is the second most
popular uh way of treating this opening
so not going for the absolute main line
but making room for this c3 pawn to be
pushed forward as you can have this very
impressive center uh magnus continues in
a way very principled uh for this uh
french he goes c5 attacks white center
and now as the knight moved we can
defend it with c3 knights to c6 we have
knight to f3 and bishop to e7 and a3 now
we have castles by magnus and knight to
f4 you can see that white is preparing
um well to have a hopefully a static
static center and then all of his pieces
will go after carlson's king if you can
get some h4 action and maybe bring the
rook into the game if you go knight g5
at some point put the queen on c2 bishop
on d3 you're gonna have a very nice
attack in formation but magnus goes
queen to a5 and this is still uh nothing
new uh the problem is uh here some moves
like bishop to e3 bishop to d3 these are
all known ideas but the muharri krishna
plays is a new move uh and that move is
pawn to b4 uh and uh as you guys might
expect the great things will happen from
this moment on so as a move 10 we have a
completely new game let's see how magnus
deals with this and why the b4 move has
been even played well it's a pretty
standard idea as
pretty much
like like it always is when you play b4
you want
uh well uh
get rid of black's uh strong grasp on
the center of the board so after uh
black captures would see captures on b4
he will no longer be attacking your d4
pawn and then you can focus on doing
things on the king's side
magnus accepts the challenge he plays c
captures on b4 and now bishop to d3
offering yet another pawn uh well hardy
does this for rapid development
magnus accepts the second challenge as
well and now okay you might um run into
some c to check idea so first we have to
block this which tempo as now we are
attacking the h7 pawn and you could
defend this with playing g6 maybe f5
maybe h6 all of these are good ideas uh
magnus plays h6 and now rook to b1 so
you can see uh hari krishna is getting
some very very impressive development
for the price of two pawns uh and now
magnus could continue with some a6b5
ideas and try to
you know prove that those pawn
sacrifices were not all that correct but
magnus instead decides to sacrifice a
piece uh or rather he's already up to
pawn so he's gonna collect two more and
then it'll be like he gave up a piece
for four pawns which is uh well not a
bad deal so he plays knight captures on
d4 completely shattering white center
knight captures on d4 and now knight
captures an e5 so now if you count the
pawns white four pawns and magnus eight
pawns he still has all of his pawns not
only that he has a past c pawn already
on c3 so here bishop to e2
he doesn't want to allow a knight to
trade for this bishop here and now comes
knight to c6
interestingly the position is already
close to winning for magnus but like i
said this is a rapid game you have to uh
well you you would have to really spend
time to find this but bishop to d7
is the way to go after the bishop comes
to a4 then you kick away the queen then
the pawn comes to
all
c2
it's all very very interesting but you
have to calculate rook captures on b7
and this is rapid you only have 15
minutes so you can't allow this but for
your viewing pleasure i will of course
show it bishop to a4 attacks the queen
now comes knight to b3 we attack blank's
queen now bishop the d6 we removed this
bishop that's um that that was a target
for the rook from b7 and now white will
just castle and now rook after b8 and
we'd say all right now white
is is close to losing this game uh
because there really isn't a good move
you can play here for example if you
just trade or captures captures and
trade queens knight captures bishop
captures yes you are still up a piece
but let's say after bishop to a3 we're
gonna move the bishop back bishop the a4
pawn is coming to c2 and black is
winning this so
very very uh interesting but of course
impossible to spot in such little time
so magnus continues with knight to c6 he
offers a trade of knights and now just
knight back to b3 attacking the queen
here magnus brings the queen back queen
to d8 and now comes queen to d3 and this
is very interesting queen captures and
c3 is a very straightforward way of sort
of equalizing uh queen to d3 uh leaves
all the complexities on the board and
allows magnus to continue having his
past c3 pawn uh but white will have some
attacking chances i guess so magnus
defends it with d4 and now knight to h5
now we are already threatening some
bishop captures on h6 ids and magnus
well he doesn't believe this he just
plays e5
and this is now
extremely dangerous for both of them as
look at this massive one poncho in the
center of the board
but
magnus is allowing bishop captures on h6
and while this should be played hari
krishna doesn't play it but i will show
it as it's again beautiful the bishop of
course cannot be accepted if the bishop
is accepted then queen g3 and then it's
uh well just lost for well it's not lost
but uh for example if you move the king
you're getting checkmated if bishop g5
you're gonna play h4 and already you can
see that white is definitely having all
the compensation white needs so you're
going to have to play something like
queen to d6 then comes the bishop
captures on g7 attacking the rook and
even rook d8 but this does not look like
something you want to have
in a rapid game so instead after e5 we
have just castles by hari krishna and
now magnus kicks away the knight with
the g6 with knight back to g3
and h5 now the situation on the clock as
i know you guys are interested in this
is uh six minutes for hari
and two minutes for magnus and here we
have f4 trying to destroy carlson's
strong center here
and now magnus plays e captures an f4
very interesting would be just the
immediate h4
but magnus doesn't want to allow
things to get too complicated because of
course if you just move the knight in
bishop to f5 is fine but what if f5
comes on the board yeah it's not
something you want to play really h
captures and g3 are gonna capture here
and even after queen d6 going after the
pawn bishop h6 could be could be very
tricky so magnus doesn't want this he
plays e captures on f4 and after bishop
captures on f4 he plays h4 now kicking
away the knight knights the e4 and now
bishop to f5 pinning the knight here
also very interesting is just f5 because
what is white doing with the knight we
were we're going to have to go into
something like queen to c for checking
h7 and knight to f2 but this looks like
uh well not the greatest square for
tonight the g5 attacks the bishop and
then the pawns continue marching forward
but still uh carlson's king would get a
little bit overexposed maybe here so he
just prefers to keep it safe
bishop to f5 and now we have g4
attacking white's bishop
offering this h captures on g for alpha
which is what magnus goes for with
bishop captures on g3 and now queen to
d5 activating the queen fully now
threatening to capture the knight here
so bishop to f3 and now knight to e5
attacking the queen and here there is no
good move for white but hardy of course
has to try everything at his disposal to
not lose the game he finds knight to f6
check and we reach the position from the
thumbnail where white is forking the
black king and queen
also white is attacking the black queen
on d5 but magnus is attacking the white
queen on d3 and here we have bishop
captures on f6
queen captures on f5 a very important in
between move and now
magnus plays knight captures on f3 with
check which is not necessary however
magnus is incredibly low on time here
and he doesn't uh find a calm queen to
d6 or queen to d8 where the white queen
is now under attack white queen has to
move and then you continue with your
plan of pushing pawns activating the uh
the rest of your pieces uh how but you
know
he he is already below with the one
minute mark so he plays knight captures
on f3 with check queen captures and he
goes for a queen trade captures captures
and bishop to g7 and now we have this
end game where magnus is up four pawns
but hari krishna is up a full knight so
how will this go knight to e1 a1 he
wants to go to c2 then go after the pawn
and now rook after e8 we have king to f1
not allowing the rook to infiltrate now
comes to rook a to d8 so fully
mobilizing the rooks and now rook to d1
so the situation on the clock is uh 3
minutes and 30 seconds for hari and less
than a minute for magnus so here we have
b5 magnus wants to play a5 b4 and get
all of his pawns rolling and now knight
to c2 here preparing to go after the
pawn uh with with ideas like bishop to
f2 and then everything will go after the
pawn also the rook can come to d3 so a5
and now bishop to f2 and now magnus
fairly quickly played rook to b8
now interestingly uh b4 is the strongest
idea here for black but it's uh it seems
to be insufficient because after
captures and captures uh we can play
knight captures on b4 and after rook to
b8 we can simply play bishop captures on
d4 that's the problem we give up the
piece and after we'll capture some b4
we're gonna play bishop captures on c3
and we get to this position where black
is up only uh only upon and this should
not be enough for black to win the game
uh so here magnus plays rook to b8
instead uh now comes bishop captures on
d4 and now he does get to push his b4
pawn a captures on b4a captures bishop
captures on g7 king captures and now uh
now you have to play rook to b1 but it's
uh as as we've already shown we have to
give up this this knight for a pawn
after rook to b1 uh b3 can be played but
now we just play rook captures on c3
that's the whole point after b captures
rook captures on b8 captures rook
captures here and again black is up upon
we are we are gonna draw this however
here knight the a1 was played and there
are a couple of moments where uh
in the video that i could have used for
the pause the video moment but i kind of
like this one the best because it's
something that actually wasn't played so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the absolute best and only
winning move for magnus while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on being a true
master of the end game i have no doubt
you spend every available moment of your
free time studying the end game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course rook eat d8 that's
the winning idea but again not an easy
one to spot uh the problem is uh what
can white play play here if you move the
rook then you allow rook to d2 and then
of course this is uh not just losing but
also visually losing so here we're going
to have to avoid the trade with rook to
b1 now comes rook to a8 uh and now again
what can you play you can't capture the
b4 pawn because the knight here is
hanging you're going to play knight to
b3 now we play rook to a2 this is how we
infiltrate and now after something like
rook to f2 offering a trade of rooks now
we play c2 and after rook to c1 now rook
d3 we go after the knight and now the
problem is you would gladly give up the
knight but there's just no good way to
do it after something like knight to d2
we're gonna play rook captures on d2
rook captures on d2 and b3 and now white
is up a full rook but it doesn't matter
at some point or white will have to give
up a rook for for one or two of these
past pawns and then uh of course we're
going to win the game it's very unlikely
that you will be able to grab both of
them because after b2 is played uh
that's uh that's just the game uh but
this was not played like i said magnus
is below the one minute mark he played
rook to a8 first and this does not work
without the inclusion of rook to d8 so
here uh we have a rook to f2 first uh
now if you go knight to c2 again uh you
could play this but then after b3 we
just play rook captures on c3 and we
don't care b captures rook captures and
white is very happy here he defended
well so instead rook f2
and now f5 by magnus now he starts
pushing the pawns we have knight to b3
now the knight is successfully brought
back into the game rook to e3 now comes
rook to b1 and now rook to c8 so magnus
now is ready to push the pawn knight to
d4 gaining control over the c2 square
and also the knight here controls not
only c2 but b3 so rook to c4
attacking the knight and now knight to
c2 attacking the b for pawn so rook eat
the e4 not just the b4 pawn the rook is
also attacked so rook here guards the
the b4 pawn and now rook to e2 offering
a trade of rooks uh rook to h4 just
keeping an eye on the the spawn avoiding
the trade and now king the g2 so how do
you uh proceed here well king to f6 this
is a very very uh intense end game and
it's uh well uh objectively it's a draw
but uh both players are now very low on
the clock and it's not easy to play we
have h3 king to g5 now comes king to h2
we have king to f6 king to g3 g5 magnus
not interested in a repetition rook beat
the e1 now doubling on the e file going
after this check so rook to c6 magnus
prevents check and now rook to b1 again
with a double attack on the b4 pawn rook
to b6 defending and now rook to b3 we
have king to g6 now comes rook to e8 and
here uh rook to d6 ready to infiltrate
with the rook but now you have to play
rook captures on b4 this is the only way
for white to play this rook captures
and now of course we don't trade but the
point is after rook to d3 check king f2
rook d2 check we have the rook on the e
file to help block this check and now
white is perfectly fine however hari
krishna played rook to g8 check first uh
magnus played king to f6 and now rook to
f8 with check the problem here is that
now now once you've moved the rook away
from the e file you can no longer play
this because now of course rook to d3
checking will move rook to d to check uh
the knight is not defended and you don't
really have all that uh
much counter play it's going to be like
the king g3 f4 checking f3 we can even
capture on h3 with check king to e4 rook
to e2 check now once the king moves
we're going to capture on c2 the pawn is
defended everything is defended we're
just up three pawns of course now this
will be completely winning so instead
after king of six rook to f8 to check we
have king to e6 and now rook to e8 with
check king f7 rook to e2 now
but it uh doesn't really help because
rook to d3 and now how do you play this
we have king to g2 or you block with
with a move like rook to e3 but then we
just capture rook captures knight
captures and then of course f4 check
wins the game so here king to g2 now
comes f4 threatening f3 with check so
here rook to f2 defending against this
but now rook d captures on h3 and now we
are up four pawns or rather we have four
points for a piece uh and this is
completely winning for magnus knight
characters and b4 was played but now
it's much too late because it's actually
a forced mate in three rook to h2 uh
herrera rook to g3 with chuck king the
f1 rook to h1 with check and he was in
this position on move 61 that uh pentala
hari krishna resigned in the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
after king t2 is played rook to e3 will
be checkmate as the pawn covers the d2
square and the rook covers the entire
first rank
so uh really a wonderful game a lot of
moments going back and forth the
evaluation bar really uh you know felt
like it was playing ping pong with
itself about uh 61 moves off of intense
action and this is why rapid chess is so
interesting uh hari krishna brought a
lot of a lot of fun
and the thrill to the table with that b4
idea sacrificing b4 and c3
but magnus was able to to grab the pawns
and well yeah it's it takes two to
create a great game and uh here
hare krishna just allowed it especially
after uh he played this queen to d3 move
going for
uh trying to keep the queen on the slide
square diagonal and allowing the
opponent c3 to survive uh
that that's
where the game for the fifth time became
incredibly interesting uh but yeah
that's the game story for a bit of a
longer recap but as you've seen it it
was quite the game so uh thank you all
for watching uh i would like to thank
brooks alizean force uh cds for trade
team of solo and kojo wushu for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
charity cup uh until it ends uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day